so today I'm going to do something I've
never done before I'm going to phone a
number file viewer and the reason for
that is this viewer has a very special
phone number so while I get ready to do
this let's get on with the video
this came from Grady so you heard of
this type of number so it was a type of
them called pandigital numbers and then
when you mentioned it I said well I've
heard upon digital numbers and I even
have a favorite one so that says start
off my favourite pandigital number I'll
show you what they are as well 381
million six hundred and fifty four
thousand seven hundred and twenty ninth
this is my favorite pandigital number
well first of all what's a planned
digital number you may notice from that
number it uses every digit and it uses
every digit once there from one to nine
so that's that's called a pandigital
number this one's my favorite it has an
extra property because the first ten
digits of it is divisible by n I'll show
you what I mean the first digit is
divisible by one the first two digits
are divisible by two the first three
digits so 381 is a number divisible by
three verse four is a number divisible
by four that's divided by five now can
be divided by six seven eight and nine
so and that's the only pandigital number
where that works so this is a unique
pandigital number with that special
property
it hasn't got a zero it hasn't got a
zero so there are different definitions
for pandigital numbers some are more
strict than others so some definitions
allow you to repeat the numbers so you
can repeat the digits as long as you
have all of them some of you don't allow
you to repeat the digits some
definitions allow you to have zero so
that one would be a zero less pandigital
number if you like though try stick zero
in it like what I could do is put zero
on the end and then there's a number
that can be divided by ten as well and
that's also unique so that would be a
unique pandigital number including zero
that could be divided by ten of course
we can't divide by zero
nice improvisation there you like that
yeah
so you've probably figured out by now
the person I'm going to call has a pen
digital phone number I found out about
it by putting a message out on Facebook
and Twitter so if you don't follow
numberphile on Facebook and Twitter
that's something you need to be doing
but before I make this phone call here's
James with a bit more information about
paying digital numbers the smallest
pandigital number pun digital by the way
it sounds like a radio station on Never
Land did you like that there you go
there you go here we go
I mean Penn digital sound like a really
modern way of cooking pan digital yeah I
agree I like that too
the smallest time digital number is it's
1 billion this was has a zebra in it so
1 billion so and the rest twenty three
million four hundred fifty six thousand
and seven hundred and eighty nine so you
can kind of see that that one's the
smallest pandigital because you can't
put the zero at the start you can see
why that's the smallest pandigital
number his his another type of
pandigital number this ones are going to
be a square and so that's can be nine
billion eight hundred and fourteen
thousand seventy two thousand three
hundred and fifty six that's not
necessarily the largest pandigital
number bates the largest square pan
digitally so that's square because it
has a square root that is a whole number
as well at draw me to check it three
five six and i want to check that's a
square number yeah look at that so nine
ninety 9066 is a cool number is it it's
it ninety nine thousand and sixty six or
is it ninety nine thousand and sixty six
I'm not sure I'm not sure what it is I
see what you're doing what are they call
numbers are the same upside down oh
there must be a name for that weird or
different for you on there I don't know
that was an interesting fact yeah oh but
you're like a you're like a prime rate
you owe from 10 you want a prime pipe
and digital numbers I thought you'd like
that so it's 10 billion 123456789
how many pundits the numbers are there
if we get really strict first of all so
we use every digit once and once only
then it's just rearranging the first
these numbers here from one to nine I'll
not include zero to start with because
that's going to make things a bit more
difficult and the number of ways you can
rearrange the numbers from one to nine
to make a pan dish number it's going to
be nine factorial nine factorial which
is 360 two thousand eight hundred and
eighty and I reckon if we are allowed to
have zero as well then it could go
anywhere except the first place so a
with the zero it's going to be at nine
times nine factorial 3 million 265
thousand nine hundred and twenty this is
obviously purely a recreational thing
that's a recreational thing and I know
some people don't like us when we're
doing things that are base 10 centric
and this is a base 10 centric little fun
thing to do if we tried base 2 which
only allows us to use ones and zeros
well then all numbers are going to be
pandigital in that case except for
numbers that are one less than a power
of two because input in base 2 those are
1 1 1 1 1 1 1 11 the only ones that
wouldn't be pandigital so here we go I'm
going to be calling this number File
Viewer lara who is in the netherlands
with a pen digital number and if you
don't include the area code it's a
brilliant pen digital number very pure
every digit just once shall we give it a
go I have no idea what's going to happen
here hello is that Lara hi yeah Lara its
Brady Haran here hi how are you doing
she's going into the other room for the
card hear you very well
ok alright I should be able for you now
so I have to say this is the first time
I've ever found a pen digital
phone number really oh well I think so I
don't know it's the first time I've done
it knowingly I'm always telling people
while they give them my phone number I
go looking at Zolder and have all the
numbers I'll call that and nobody ever
thinks it's cool but I do oh well I
think it's very cool and I think a lot
of the people who watch our video would
think it's very cool okay what do you
tell us about you like what do you do
and stuff
I got a psychology psychology student
yeah what are you doing watching
numberphile videos I really like that
fun very bad in it so numberphile is
sort of a a comfortable intrigue but for
me well we're obviously not going to
tell anyone your phone number but thank
you for sharing the glory of your paired
digital phone number with us yeah it is
good yeah thanks so much for being part
of I guess bit of a silly video but
hopefully when you watch it you'll learn
lots of other stuff about Penn digital
numbers do yeah a little bit
excellent well you're the star of the
show now so I hope you're looking
forward to it all right
all the best have a good evening yeah
you too bye bye bye there you go
pandigital phone number how cool is that
a special thanks to squarespace.com for
supporting this video Squarespace is
this all-in-one platform for designing
websites and blogs and online stores why
don't you check them out these are some
websites that have been designed using
it they're pretty slick looking much
more impressive than the numberphile
website so go and have a look it's free
to join up and if you decide to use it
and purchase anything from them you can
actually get 10% off by using
numberphile 5 as the voucher code I
actually contacted them and asked if we
could change it to numberphile and then
a pandigital number but I think someone
decided that would probably be a bit
complicated so we're going with
numberphile 5 anyway enough about that
Squarespace comm free to join up if you
buy anything use the code numberphile 5
and thanks to them for supporting us and
helping us make videos